la fiac à paris est devenue l'une des
plus grandes foires internationales
d'art contemporain au monde
pourtant voici les images de la première
édition c'était en 1974 salon
international d'art contemporain paris
du 26 janvier au 3 février 1974 pavillon
d'exposition de la bastille
grosse grosse ambiance en 74 dans
l'ancienne gare de la bastille
rien à voir avec la cohue d'aujourd'hui
mais pourquoi avoir voulu un salon d'art
contemporain à paris un concept qui
existait déjà à bâle en suisse depuis
parce que cette fois on donne un bon
reflet de l'art moderne
oui je crois que c'est la foire presque
la meilleur équilibre et vis-à-vis des
autres c'est assez très étendue et on
dit que c'est la meilleure balle
référence dans l'art paris mise au rebut
piqué au vif c'est ainsi que des
galeristes parisiens lance le concept
d'un salon d'art contemporain qui
prendra plus tard le nom de fiac
l'artiste ben faisait partie des 110
exposants lors de la première édition et
il expliquait d'ailleurs le concept
d'art contemporain quoi que vous passiez
ici c'est périmé d'avancé de la forme la
couleur le mach est acceptée demande
dans périmés d'avant mais pour certains
cet art n'est pas périmés mais source de
rentabilité
car ne l'oublions pas les artistes sont
présents pour vendre et en 1974 juste
après la crise pétrolière
le journaliste faisait très vite le
rapprochement économique
est ce que vous ne pensez pas aussi que
les problèmes économiques actuels vont
pousser certains à venir ici faire des
placements
écoutez je crois que nous nous plaçons
de ce point de vue là dans une bonne
conjoncture économique n'est pas douteux
que l'art est bon pour ceux qu'ils
l'aiment
mais qu' il peut réserver également de
très bonnes surprises
depuis cette première édition la fiac a
su s'imposer mais la foire suisse
art basel est toujours considérée comme
la mecque de l'art contemporain et la
fiac peut avoir des airs de réchauffer
exemple pour l'édition de la foire
parisienne de 2018
89 galerie présente au grand palais ont
déjà exposé à la foire de bâle en juin
dernier
[Musique]